[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tom pellicero covers the nfl nfl network
and uh he joins us on the program all
right go ahead build your build your
team tom who's your quarterback running
back wide receiver right wide receiver
tight end
well dude i first want to say when i
initially saw that list uh i'm wondering
are we playing with 10 men on offense
because i'm pretty sure you get either a
third receiver a second tight end to
fullback
so we really could add one a flex spot
uh if you will my list is not that
different i think it has to be
tom brady at quarterback just based upon
the
the history and seven championships i
think it's got to be
you know running back is the hardest one
for me i would lean toward barry sanders
because of what he did in the amount of
time that he did it jim brown's before
my time uh emmitt smith walter paytner
in that conversation i'd say it's very
wide receiver jerry rice and i would say
randy moss just because you know i
remember watching him in 1998 and
literally changed the way defenses had
to play changed the way i mean the
packers in 1999 drafted i think corners
with their first three picks because
they realized we're gonna have to deal
with this guy forever and rob gronkowski
because he's the biggest match-up
nightmare that we've ever uh ever seen
at tight end
yeah i don't know if they're you know
you can have favorites you know fritzy's
a bronco fan so he puts in john elway or
uh puts in uh shannon sharp
um and i have no problem with elway in
there either because we can look at tom
brady and say the resume
like but is he the best quarterback
you know
and and
he won all these super bowls but is he
still the best quarterback have you said
hey
you know joe montana you got to win a
game uh or whoever your quarterback
might be or john elway
is tom brady the best
quarterback in that situation
i think it depends how you define best
because i don't think that you would
look at last season remember when the
bucks went into their buy in november
they weren't playing well offensively
they were kind of a mess they looked
like an average team we were wondering
are they even gonna make the playoffs
they obviously adjusted the offense it's
became a lot more like what brady had
been running in new england they went on
an all-time
epic run but i don't think if you said
the body of work in 2020 was tom brady
even in the top five quarterbacks for
the if you take the entirety of the
season yeah probably not
but there's more to playing quarterback
than just being able to make
unbelievable throws or run like lamar
jackson or you know the freaky things
you do with your arm like patrick
mahomes i think that you have to look at
the it is the intangibles it is the
leadership that you bring to the
position it's the consistency over a
great number of years that uh tom brady
has shown i mean we can always go back
to you know let's say eight years ago
where there was a stretch of about a
decade where the patriots didn't win a
super bowl and there were times where it
was raised you know when they start out
off to a bad start and how much longer
does tom have then the guy goes to win
several more championships i mean we've
never seen
anything like that and just the the
singular the one driving force between
those titles is tom brady even going to
a new building last year in tampa having
coveted no off season just kind of
rolling out there completely changed the
culture of the team and they won a super
bowl against what i would say would be
all odds based on how they were playing
just a couple months before the
championship game tom pelicero nfl
network reporter and uh thursday night
football continues this week jets colts
that's on fox nfl network and amazon
prime video
i was wondering if uh i gave sean payton
a do-over given the michael thomas news
that he's now out for the year would
they have made a run at odell beckham or
should they have brought in maybe teddy
bridgewater tried to see if the broncos
were willing to trade him and pay part
of that salary uh the saints didn't do
anything how surprising was that
well they tried the saints were actively
involved on talks for wide receivers in
particular darius slayton was one
at some point there may have been a
conversation about odell beckham jr too
the issue with the conversations
yesterday and obviously they were
sparked by odell beckham senior and
lebron james saying various things about
freeing odell from cleveland there was
no way that the browns could trade that
contract and it was too late to eat
money like the broncos did uh with
vaughn miller so beckham's do 14.5
million this year in base salary almost
the entire thing is fully guaranteed a
new team saints or otherwise would have
had to take on 8.5 million dollars
there's nobody in the league who is
trying to take on any salary hardly much
less take on that amount of money for a
guy who just hasn't been that productive
if you and our research people pulled up
these numbers yesterday baker mayfield
his passer rating is 20 points lower
this season throwing to odell versus
anybody else and baker mayfield has the
lowest passer rating to odell beckham jr
the lowest passer rating for a duo of
anybody in the league going back to 2019
with at least 100 attempts those two for
whatever reason and obviously there's a
throw in minnesota baker just misses
odell could be a game-winning play could
change the entire tenor of the
conversation for whatever reason those
two have never clicked three years the
chemistry is not there that contract
just isn't tradable for a guy who's got
what 17 catches no touchdowns this
season uh you know and frankly if odell
had not had a contract guarantee kick in
while he was still rehabbing from his
acl he probably wouldn't even be on the
browns this season
yeah it's just weird that you know
people keep bringing up odell beckham
and you know he brings about clicks you
know when you talk about odell beckham
and baker mayfield it's clicks therefore
he gets he's overexposed and and right
now overrated but i can still watch a
game and i don't hear his name called
tom like this is a guy that i'm being
told oh you know he's generational
talent
is this design is it
uh like how do you have a lack of
chemistry communication or whatever it
is with somebody that great that somehow
you're not on the same page with it
well that's the real question because
these guys have had even though odell's
had some injuries obviously the acl last
year he was limited through the course
of training camp they've had a lot of
time on task together and for whatever
reason it has not clicked now odell has
had i think 34 targets this season he's
had 17 catches so that's 50
which again not a very good number he's
dropped a couple passes he had
opportunities on fourth down a couple of
weeks ago didn't haul him in he's
playing with a significant shoulder
injury right now too but you have to
evaluate uh as part of the conversation
i go back to training camp this year and
you know at that time odell was not
doing team drills yet this is like
halfway through training camp but you
stand there on the sideline and you
watch him and the quick twitch that he
has to him how fast he is how agile he
is and you still go how is this guy not
one of the best receivers in the nfl and
certainly possible in another system or
with a different quarterback
there might be more opportunities out
there for him but right now he's playing
in an offense in cleveland that has been
since kevin stefanski got there really
really productive centers around the run
game nick chubb and when he's healthy
kareem hunt the passing game in some
regards comes second so he's never going
to get you know it's not going to be the
ben mcadoo giants offense where
basically they made the playoffs that
year because they threw it to him 20
times a game and just were like odell
try to make something happen so we got
nothing else going on it's never going
to be like that in cleveland you know
odell i'm sure in his mind and i haven't
spoken to him about it but i would guess
he still believes he's one of the best
receivers in the nfl he could put up
those monster numbers the offense isn't
really geared to do that but when you
get the opportunities you have to find a
way to connect and baker and odell
haven't done that
i was told yesterday by source that uh
denver is is loading up for aaron
rodgers that they know that the packers
like draft picks you know they don't go
the free agent market very often that
they're going to load up if he's going
to be available there and that's why
when you trade von miller pick up his
salary and but you're getting a second
and third round pick like we got to have
a nice
uh
gift offering to the packers to get
aaron rodgers what do you think of that
philosophy by denver
i think it's fair to say
the broncos as of now
don't know that they have the
quarterback of the future on the roster
teddy bridgewater coming in from
carolina i think for a sixth round pick
beats out drew lock former second
rounder it's fair to say you're not
committed to either of those guys as
your long-term quarterback so whether
it's aaron rodgers or something else the
broncos absolutely are loaded up on
capital to have the flexibility to go
out and get a quarterback they've been
connected to aaron rodgers he was the
mvp of the nfl last season he's playing
at a really high level now uh aaron told
people going back into the offseason
with all the drama that denver was a
place that he wanted to be
and we'll see who the head coach ends up
being in denver too which also could you
know alter exactly how aaron rodgers
looks at things in terms of you know
where he wants to land think about this
though we had so much quarterback
movement last offseason beginning with
matthew stafford agreeing to part ways
with the lions he gets traded to the
rams you had carson wentz who was on the
move you had obviously rumors and some
reality too to russell wilson aaron
rodgers well in this offseason now
desean watson did not get traded that is
an extraordinarily complicated situation
including the serious allegations of
sexual misconduct you have russell
wilson we don't know exactly what
direction that's going to go you have
aaron rodgers even though the packers
are playing well and suddenly aaron is
throwing some bouquets to brian
guticunes to the front office about the
moves that they have made which don't
overlook that
uh all three of those guys potentially
could be available this is not regarded
as a really good class in the draft in
terms of quarterbacks when i've talked
to scouts and gm's and they're flying
around the country watching these guys
it's not a really highly regarded group
now is somebody going to make one of
those guys into the number one overall
pick history would say yes someone will
convince themselves to do it but if
you're looking for a quarterback in 2022
and it's quite likely that the broncos
will be you're certainly inclined to be
looking at those potential veteran
options over the draft and there's at
least three guys not even counting the
one-year contract guys the jameis
winstons of the world uh there's three
guys who everyone's going to be looking
at and those deals once again could come
well before the start of free agency on
march 16. and
and i had a source saying you know roger
still wants to get back out west that i
think he thought that he was going to go
to the rams that that maybe that was
going to be the possibility or he could
go to the niners
you know when you start going out west
how many teams are out west um that's
why i got quarterbacks yeah and that's
why denver seems like the the option the
question is
i mean who knows what happens the rest
of the year playoffs you know any of
that stuff but i i did think that denver
has a philosophy here you'll you'll have
a new head coach next year um
you know they're going to try to do you
know john elway is probably going to try
to do what he did with uh manning you
know re recruit aaron rodgers the best
he can and uh
you know i think it flied to aaron
rodgers like didn't he do that with
peyton manning like he wanted peyton so
badly he's like i'm i'm gonna fly to you
i i want to bring you in and maybe maybe
that's what the philosophy is if you're
giving up on von miller and
uh that's a you know it's an interesting
team though tom i think denver quietly
has a young nucleus that could be
a surprise team it's just in that
division you better have yourself a
quarterback because everybody else has a
quarterback even the raiders with derek
carr
well if you're looking at the weapons
and i can guarantee you aaron rodgers
did that last offseason when he was
having various conversations and hoping
that he was going to be potentially
playing someplace other than green bay i
mean javonte williams is a good young
running back uh obviously melvin gordon
in that backfield too jerry judy
cortland sutton at the wide receiver
positions noah fan to tight end they've
invested in the offensive line and
defensively even though you know you're
going through a transition bradley chubb
hasn't stayed healthy you got patrick
certain it looks like a really good
young corner yeah there's absolutely
some building blocks and yet to credit
their new gm george payton just for what
he has done being able to amass assets
right now not necessarily compromising
this season because they're still in the
playoff race in the afc it's just it's
impossible to pass up a second and third
round pick for a guy in von miller who
in all likelihood was not going to be
with the broncos uh beyond this season
anyway so yes there's definitely some
building blocks in place uh you can also
bet though aaron rodgers is going to
want to know who is the head coach vic
fangio's in his third year there we'll
see how the rest of this season goes if
there's somebody that aaron rodgers
likes who lands that job or a different
job that certainly could uh influence
his thinking and at some point aaron
rodgers too remember he's still under
contract for 2022 so there's a
conversation that's going to take place
after this season we'll see what
direction it goes i mean even if they
win the super bowl that does not
necessarily guarantee everything is
kumbaya aaron rodgers wants to stay
there so we'll see exactly how this
entire thing plays out but at that point
the packers if aaron rodgers says listen
even though we won big or we didn't win
big whatever it is i still want out the
packers will have two options one is to
say aaron you got one you're left on
this con on your contract you have we're
gonna make you play that out and then
you can walk in free agency or the
packers can say
we know we can trade this guy right now
potentially for multiple first-round
picks build around jordan love reboot
the whole thing as opposed to rogers
walking after 2022 i was getting a third
round comp pick in 2023 that's a
critical evaluation and i'm sure that's
something mark murphy bryan gudekunst
and company have already been thinking
through even at a time where if you
watch the packers play right now i can't
imagine anybody as much as you want to
think long term but i can't imagine
anybody is rooting for aaron rodgers to
be someplace other than green bay in
2020 uh the rams philosophy what do you
make of it
it's fascinating in fact i was talking
with a gm about this yesterday who said
you know he thought what they're doing
is pretty cool because nobody's done
this i mean this is breaking
the mold of the last 20 years of roster
building in terms of giving up virtually
all your draft picks next year and
listen they can still get comp picks and
returns if you look at some of those
things that von walks for instance after
this season you give up a second and
third to denver well you get a third
back it's out in 2023 but you get that
back if on signs elsewhere potentially
in free agency uh but they have they've
leveraged themselves to the hilt i mean
they've been extremely aggressive going
all the way back to you know last year
when they ate todd gurley's salary to
release him they had to find a taker for
jared goff and they gave him multiple
ones
along to get matthew stafford out to la
now you give up two more draft picks you
got virtually no draft capital in 2022
but they're going for it they're in a
competitive market in la they have to
look at the chargers not that it's a
competition necessarily but you're
playing in the same stadium i would
imagine when the chargers are playing
well they got a hot young quarterback in
justin herbert you're thinking well we
gotta make sure that we're going for it
every year so that's what they've done
and i said this you know all the way
back in march one of the dynamics i
think is fascinating is matthew stafford
through his entire career has obviously
been a really good quarterback but he's
never had pressure on him before in
other words every time that the lions
either got to the playoffs they go nine
and seven they lose in the first round
again where they go six and ten nobody
was going they gotta get rid of stafford
everyone's going it's the lions or the
lion if only he weren't on the lions
well that's gone now you have everything
around you uh if you're stafford you
know he always he plays hurt he takes a
lot of knicks he kind of keeps himself
going i think that's going to be one of
the story lines of this entire you know
stretch run of the season and into
january is just matthew stafford on the
biggest stage for the first time in his
career
there's no excuses and i think a lot of
matthew is a person i haven't dealt with
him through the years he's obviously
been again a really good player but now
the pressure's on it's on john mcveigh
it's on the rest of that staff because
if you don't win this year after you
went for it you got to pay for that in
some regard because of the capital
you've given up in the future
great stuff tom thank you have a great
weekend
anytime dad thanks that's tom pelicero
covers the nfl for the nfl network